all right what's going on guys this is  Rob and uh I'd love this to qualify as a  short or not but I have ADHD like super  bad and I'm looking for an anime to  watch and I need your all suggestions I  have seen death note I got bored as hell  that show went on just way too long so I  was like okay it should have ended when  L died  um I haven't really watched Cowboy Bebop  I watched the first episode but I just  got bored and turned it off so uh I need  something like fast paced right  something like just super fast paced  Crazy Action stuff like that that's what  I need from an anime because anything  else and it just makes me bored let me  know down in the comments pretty